I work for the European Commission in
director-general for enlargement and in
that director-general I work in the
kosovo issues unit I work in the General
Secretariat of the European Parliament
and more concretely in the Secretariat
of the Subcommittee on Human Rights at
the moment I work in tt energy I'm in
charge of planning the work of the
Directorate General in the context of
the Commission's objectives and
priorities I studied international
politics and during my studies I felt
something was missing so I added
international law to it so I graduated
twice actually international law and
international politics
I studied Business Administration in
Austria and then after my studies I did
master's in politics and the European
Public Administration in Belgium I
studied actually interpretation and
translation English and German but then
I realized that interpreting was a very
hard job for me and I did kind of a
u-turn and started and with a master's
in political science and European
studies when I joined the Commission I
started in the area of justice and Home
Affairs in planning and reporting policy
planning and reporting that meant
coordinating the policy activities of
the DG and trying to make sure that they
fit into the Commission overall
priorities I then changed to external
relations I was in charge of the Western
Balkans in the area of Home Affairs and
at the moment I'm in DG energy again
working on policy planning and reporting
in the Commission there is a lot of
opportunities to do different sorts of
jobs and and even later to switch into
other fields of work which may meet
better the personal interest at that
time
in my previous job when I was in charge
of External Relations in the area of
Home Affairs I regularly had to
accompany the Commissioner to meetings
with ministers from Western Balkan
countries and prepare these meetings and
then also ensure proper follow-up with
the countries in question that was
certainly exciting moments to meet
presidents or to meet Minister of
Interior or prime ministers of countries
of the region I think the most rewarding
aspect of the work is when you really
meet people who struggle for human
rights and you see how determined and
how motivated and how much strength they
actually have and in this sense I know
for example I was very impressed by one
of our Sahara laureates for the freedom
of thought who was 78 years old he came
to Strasbourg in December but he was for
30 years in prison and you are just
touched but by such strong people we had
a meeting with the government of Kosovo
Prime Minister and all the ministers
included where we put to them all the
problems that we've identified and also
problems that we've received the day
before from civil society organizations
so there were very some very fresh
problems and we provoked immediately a
response from the government when I
joined the Commission I spoke mostly
English French and German and in
day-to-day work I think English and to
some degree also French where my most
important languages at the moment as I
am working in a Director General that is
led by a German Commissioner German is
more important in my day-to-day work
also I have some more german-speaking
colleagues languages are certainly very
very important
I think Brussels is very welcoming for
people from outside of course there is a
large international community as well so
it's very easy to integrate very quickly
into different sports organizations or
just to walk around and explore the city
it's it's a very open and welcoming for
that I think what struck me most when I
came here and for example when I went
out is for a beer after work was that in
a small square like the plastics on walk
you can find people from 30 different
countries very compressed very open to
be in touch
interested in getting to know you you
can get to know them and that's a very
enriching and special experience that
probably you can't find anywhere else in
the world
you